let's go next to fiona from germany
fiona welcome
fiona from germany please unmute you're
on the
air and last chance for fiona from
germany to unmute you're on the air but
you must have working
hello fiona
hello how are you i'm
fine thank you sorry about my audio it
sometimes doesn't like changing channels
i would
be interested in what's like your
opinion on the german
reinvestment into military because i'm
concerned about what my government does
with talking so little to each other let
alone the general public you know
yeah i have to tell you it's not a big
shock to me that there's renewed
interest in investment in a larger
military in germany to be perfectly
honest and i think the reasons for that
are
one is a more longer-term reason and one
is more short-term
after seeing the way that the trump
presidency caused a rift with germany
which is historically in recent decades
such a great ally of the united states
it seems
logical now i don't i'm not saying i
love everybody having bigger militaries
but i'm just saying from the german
perspective
if all of a sudden
you're not quite so friendly with like
one of your big allies that also has
this massive military which is the
united states it seems completely
sensible that you would say hey we
should probably just have a bigger
military given that we don't know what
sorts of needs we might have that we
need to go go it alone for uh if there's
another trump where we're all of a
sudden not getting along so well or the
american president can't be relied upon
or is just a loose cannon so that that
to me makes a lot of sense as to why it
would make germany have a renewed
interest in having a stronger military
does that make sense
some would but i would have expected
that it would be a more european
approach especially since we still rely
on the french president to say whatever
our military is going to do like two
weeks in advance okay yeah but uh i
think that it
in even if you consider it a european
interest
i would include france in this as well i
mean all all of these western european
countries
suffered a situation during trump's four
years
where all of a sudden the u.s
was a different sort of ally than
previous to trump so it it does make a
lot of sense to me
i do get that but like
declaring national budget to me was
disturbing like
the same time it was also announced that
germany would just like put some troops
in reserve for the european commission
to uh have
emergency access to
which i believe would have been more
popular with the german general public
than uh just like throwing double the
annual budget on the military once yeah
i don't disagree with you and i'm not
saying i like it i'm just saying that
thinking about it from a geopolitical
perspective i i understand it i think
the other thing also is uh there's
probably some degree to which the
russian invasion of ukraine
is making a lot of countries just kind
of reevaluate um
their military capabilities and it
wouldn't be surprising to me that that
might also push some militaries or some
countries to want to strengthen the
military either although that's more of
a short term hopefully a short-term
thing
thanks for taking my question my
pleasure fiona from germany what a call
what a call
we have a situation right now where many
companies want and need to hire people
quickly
but it is difficult to find the right
candidates and workable is going to help
workable accelerates every step of your
hiring process workable helps you cast
the widest net possible by posting your
jobs to over 200 of the top job boards
with just one click it helps you
evaluate and hire quickly with modern
tools like video interviews and
e-signatures you can automate some of
those repetitive tasks like scheduling
interviews whether you're hiring for
your coffee shop or your engineering
team workable is exactly what you need
to hire the right people fast
start hiring today with a risk-free
15-day trial if you hire during the
trial which many do
it will cost you nothing
just go to workable.com
podcast to start hiring the link is down
below